[Music]
covering nearly 450 acres land chefs
park or landscape park is a modern
public space built on an abandoned coal
and steel production plant
and maybe the most surprising feature of
landscapes park is the converted
gasometer a natural gas container
repurposed into an indoor scuba diving
pool the largest of its kind in europe
this great big story was made possible
by the german national tourist board and
hanse merkor travel insurance
[Music]
constructed in 1991 this massive
playground attracts over a million
visitors a year
throughout the park there are multiple
high ropes courses an outside climbing
park where visitors can scale the walls
of the original structure and a viewing
deck to take in the surroundings and
relics of germany's industrial past
and in the center you'll find tauk
revere gasometer filled with over 40
million gallons of rainwater diver
christian petsack has been running the
gaza meter at lancia's park since 2006
the gas meters at landscapes park were
once used for storing gas when purified
the gas can be used to power machinery
a downturn in the city's steel and
mining sector closed the plant in 1985.
years later designers rehabilitated the
space and saw potential for a diving
center today divers can explore a unique
man-made underwater landscape
the ampersand
autofocus is
this wreckage makes the gaza meter a
popular destination for divers of all
ages
in the super optimally
[Music]
park finds new life for the discarded
and beauty and the mundane all the while
educating its countless visitors on
germany's industrial heritage
it's
[Music]
you